You have a dinner party.
The table folds out to fit 16 people in otherwise a conventional one-bedroom,
or maybe you want a dance studio.
I mean, architects have been thinking about these ideas for a long time.
What we need to do now,
develop things that can scale to those 300 million Chinese people
that would like to live in the city, and very comfortably.
We think we can make a very small apartment
that functions as if it's twice as big by utilizing these strategies.
I don't believe in smart homes. That's sort of a bogus concept.
I think you have to build dumb homes and put smart stuff in it.
(Laughter)
And so we've been working on a chassis of the wall itself.
You know, standardized platform
with the motors and the battery when it operates,
little solenoids that will lock it in place and get low-voltage power.
We think this can all be standardized,
and then people can personalize the stuff that goes into that wall,
and like the car, we can integrate all kinds of sensing
to be aware of human activity,
so if there's a baby or a puppy in the way,
you won't have a problem.
(Laughter)
So the developers say, well, this is great.
OK, so if we have a conventional building, we have a fixed envelope,
maybe we can put in 14 units.
If they function as if they're twice as big,
we can get 28 units in.
That means twice as much parking, though.
Parking's really expensive.
It's about 70,000 dollars per space
to build a conventional parking spot inside a building.
So if you can have folding and autonomy,
you can do that in one-seventh of the space.
That goes down to 10,000 dollars per car,
just for the cost of the parking.
You add shared use, and you can even go further.
We can also integrate all kinds of advanced technology
through this process.
There's a path to market for innovative companies
to bring technology into the home.
In this case, a project we're doing with Siemens.
We have sensors on all the furniture, all the infill,
that understands where people are and what they're doing.
Blue light is very efficient,
so we have these tunable 24-bit LED lighting fixtures.
It recognizes where the person is, what they're doing,
fills out the light when necessary to full spectrum white light,
and saves maybe 30, 40 percent in energy consumption, we think,
over even conventional state-of-the-art lighting systems.
This just shows you the data that comes from the sensors
that are embedded in the furniture.
We don't really believe in cameras to do things in homes.
We think these little wireless sensors are more effective.
We think we can also personalize sunlight.
That's sort of the ultimate personalization in some ways.
So we've looked at articulating mirrors of the facade
that can throw shafts of sunlight anywhere into the space,
therefore allowing you to shade most of the glass
on a hot day like today.
In this case, she picks up her phone,
she can map food preparation at the kitchen island
to a particular location of sunlight.
An algorithm will keep it in that location as long as she's engaged in that activity.
This can be combined with LED lighting as well.
We think workplaces should be shared.
I mean, this is really the workplace of the future, I think.
This is Starbucks, you know.
Maybe a third --
And you see everybody has their back to the wall
and they have food and coffee down the way
and they're in their own little personal bubble.
We need shared spaces for interaction and collaboration.
We're not doing a very good job with that.
At the Cambridge Innovation Center, you can have shared desks.
I've spent a lot of time in Finland at the design factory of Aalto University,
where the they have a shared shop and shared fab lab, shared quiet spaces,
electronics spaces, recreation places.
We think ultimately, all of this stuff can come together,
a new model for mobility, a new model for housing,
a new model for how we live and work,
a path to market for advanced technologies.
But in the end, the main thing we need to focus on are people.
Cities are all about people.
They're places for people.
There's no reason why we can't dramatically improve
the livability and creativity of cities
like they've done in Melbourne with the laneways
while at the same time dramatically reducing CO2 and energy.
It's a global imperative. We have to get this right.
Thank you.
(Applause)